[Musique]
mes parents venaient de mondes
différents
je suis le fruit d'un amour qui n'aurait
jamais dû naître tu une ira peut-être
nos mondes un beau jour vis de la terre
et fils des mères
ta mère a toujours su que tu était
exceptionnelle
paul est immense
tu es le pont entre terre et mer
je dois prendre ta place
de roi légitime
[Musique]
nous y sommes presque
ouais reste quoi parce que morts de soif
ya aucune chance catelan titre soit si
loin des côtes
c'est la folie ici ça déchire j'existe
[Musique]
elle marche pas évidemment qu'elle
marche pas la dernière fois qu'elle a
servi le sahara était pas encore
désertiques du sahara pas encore
désertique
- tu réfléchis avant d'agir et mieux tu
agis aller bouge pas 1 qu'est ce que tu
veux il nous faut de l'eau est la source
la plus proche
[Musique]
thème frileuse suffit d excuse dessus
en ce trident repouse le pouvoir
d'atlantique
[Musique]
sollicite mon pouvoir bar au delà des
confins du monde en mer cacher
en mauvaise main
le trident ne causerait que destruction
[Musique]
du vrai héritier
tous nos royaumes terrestres et marins
et minutes quoi on n'aurait pas dû noter
d'abord j'ai tout mémoriser toinon à 6
carrément il a dit quoi truc machin
bidule trident la bête s'est réveillé
il est enfin temps
cas quand hydro nes
vous êtes quoi comme bestioles
[Musique]
c'était de laval laquerre se propage à
la surface
sur sortir a vaincu
des milliards de gens mourront si tu ne
nous aide pas
[Musique]
j'ai pas l'âme d'un chef
il est un roi
[Musique]
atlantide a toujours eu un mois
aujourd'hui lui faut plus que ça
mais qu'est ce qu'il y aurait de mieux
qu'un roi un héros